es momento de hablar ahora de economía
por eso me acompañan el estudio Jorge
Hurtado Jorge muy buenas noches
comenzamos hablando de economía en el
Reino Unido este país que ya tiene su
tercer Primer Ministro a lo largo de
este año Así que hablamos de el primer
gobernante de origen indio del Reino
Unido quien no la tiene fácil debe
enderezar el rumbo económico de esa
nación que se dirige hacia una recesión
económica sunat debe calmar los mercados
Y tratar de controlar la inflación en un
momento de débilizamiento de las
finanzas públicas el empeoramiento de
las perspectivas económicas y una ola de
huelgas no es la primera vez que es una
toma el mando bajo esta presión cuando
Boris Johnson lo ascendió a canciller en
febrero del año 2020 tuvo menos de un
mes para preparar un presupuesto justo
cuando la pandemia estaba golpeando las
economías del mundo la actividad
empresarial británica se contrajo por
tercer mes consecutivo en Octubre y cayó
a su nivel más bajo desde enero del 202
lo que indica que Reino Unido podría
estar en camino hacia una profunda
recesión económica el jefe del tesoro
Jeremy Hunt nombrado por trozas hace
apenas 10 días debe hacer una
declaración presupuestaria de emergencia
el 31 de octubre
y pasemos ahora a hablar de China Jorge
porque presentó sus esperados datos
económicos del tercer trimestre Así es Y
bueno aunque el crecimiento de China
superó las previsiones el repunte no es
nada significativo la segunda economía
mundial se expandió un 3,9% entre julio
y septiembre respecto al mismo periodo
del año pasado superando el ritmo del
3,4% previsto por los economistas y un
poco más rápido que el crecimiento del
0,4% del segundo trimestre pero a nivel
interno la demanda bajó al final del
trimestre esto esto como resultado del
endurecimiento de la política 0 Mientras
que el crecimiento de las exportaciones
se ralentizó y el sector inmobiliario se
enfrió aún más la publicación de los
datos estaba prevista inicialmente para
el 18 de octubre pero se retrasó por la
celebración del congreso del partido
comunista de la semana pasada otro dato
interesante Santiago es el volumen de
comercio entre Rusia y China se aumentó
un
32,5% interanual en este trimestre Jorge
hablemos de Colombia porque como una
Tormenta perfecta catálogo JP Morgan a
la economía de este país sudamericano no
quiero ser pesimista pero tormenta no
debe traer nada bueno así es bueno es
una de las entidades más importantes y
más prestigiosas del mundo el banco
estadounidense jipi Morgan afirma que
existe en Colombia incertidumbre por
algunas propuestas del gobierno también
muchos capitales siguen de cerca la
reforma tributaria el aumento del dólar
la estabilización de los energéticos
entre otros temas según el banco y abro
comillas lo que dijo los activos locales
colombianos se dan deteriorado
materialmente en las últimas semanas en
respuesta a la disminución de la
confianza a nivel nacional una posición
débil de las cuentas externas y Fiscales
y un entorno global hostil En otras
palabras dijo una Tormenta perfecta se
espera que en los próximos días el banco
de la República sigue aumentando sus
tasas de interés para tratar de contener
la inflación esto en Colombia Mientras
tanto en Nicaragua Estados Unidos
sancionó al sector minero aurífero de
ese país centroamericano porque así Este
es el último y que se hace el más
agresivo intento de parte de Estados
Unidos de responsabilizar al gobierno de
Daniel Ortega por violaciones a los
derechos humanos y también a la
democracia de ese país junto con la
sanción simultánea del departamento del
tesoro a la dirección general de minas
de Nicaragua la orden prácticamente hace
ilegal que los estadounidenses hagan
negocios con la Industria Del Oro de
Nicaragua Es la primera vez que Estados
Unidos identifica un sector específico
de la economía como prohibido y la
sanción podría ampliarse para incluir
otras industrias que se creen tienen las
arcas del gobierno nicaragüense la orden
también abre las puertas para que
Estados Unidos restrinja la inversión y
el comercio con Nicaragua una medida que
a muchos trae recuerdos del bloqueo
impuesto por Estados Unidos en la década
de 1980 justo durante el primer gobierno
sandinista El golpe es fuerte para
Nicaragua porque el oro fue la mayor
exportación del país en 2020 Nicaragua
ya es el mayor productor de este metal
precioso en Centroamérica y planea
duplicar la producción en los próximos
cinco años pasemos ahora a hablar de
México porque publicó su dato de
inflación de la primera quincena de
octubre cómo los fue a los mexicanos
bueno el dato anual se desaceleró un
poco más de lo esperado los datos del
organismo Nacional de estadísticas Inegi
dice que la inflación general anual en
la segunda economía de América Latina
bajó un 8,53% desde el 8,64 de la
segunda mitad de septiembre pero en
comparación con la quincena anterior los
precios al consumo mexicano subieron un
0,44% a principios del mes de octubre el
Banco Central de México a Estados Unidos
los tipos de interés desde junio de 2021
en un intento para frenar la inflación
que superó el objetivo del banco que era
del 3% para este año los economistas
también esperan que el debilitamiento de
la demanda interna y el efecto
de este endurecimiento de las
condiciones financieras sigan
presionando a la baja a la inflación en
ese país y para el cierre la cifra del
día sorprendanos
4.999 pesos el precio del dólar en
Colombia estuvo a sólo un peso de los
5000 esto por varios factores sobre todo
relacionado a este endurecimiento de las
políticas monetarias a nivel global y el
fortalecimiento del dólar que afecta no
sólo a Colombia sino a varias monedas
latinoamericanas Así que lo estamos
padeciendo aquí en Colombia Muchas
gracias Jorge es todo por el momento en
la economía a continuación en directo
América ya viene el debate
[Música]